le quotidien qui change c'est la peur
qui rentre dans dans le quotidien quand
comme le disait les sia quand on se
s'informe on regarde ce qui se passe
aussi en Ukraine c'est ça c'est le
sentiment de peur qui qui prédomine
c'est pas qu'elle a peur bien évidemment
c'est la peur c'est les inquiétudes
c'est aussi la déception des se dire que
finalement nos enfants doivent connaître
ça que nos parents ils ne peuvent pas
vieillir calmement que le peuple
craignant il a qui n'a pas mérité tout
ça et enfin c'est un pays européen qui
doit malheureusement
reconnaître à nouveau la guerre qui ne
devrait plus exister sur terre je crois
que votre père est resté sur place
pendant un mois sur le front et le mari
d'Anastasia votre ami est toujours sur
place le mari d'Anastasia comme le fils
de Marie Marina sont toujours
mon père il était resté dans la ville de
tcherny if et qui a été malheureusement
beaucoup touchée à 70% de la Villette
détruite et là c'était mon quotidien
beaucoup changé par contre il y a un an
j'ai Vivé plus parce que c'était une
peur extrême de ne plus jamais pouvoir y
voir ma famille et surtout que je ne
pouvais absolument rien faire pour et
c'est la ville qui était entourée minée
il y avait absolument pas de
possibilités ni rentrer ni sortir de
l'impuissance en fait à distance c'est
ça donc je faisais tout ce que je
pouvais
envoyer les
les produits les
l'argent les
et dans la ville parce que je pouvais
absolument rien faire pour mon père mais
je me disais que si je vais pouvoir
aider la ville parce que avec la mairie
de Montigny on avait fait des récoltes
et j'ai pu par mes propres chemins
envoyer de temps de
collecte et le lendemain mon père a
réussi à sortir
donc le lendemain que tout ça c'était
arrivé à tcherny Rif mon père a réussi à
sortir et encore le jour d'après le pont
est explosé donc il y avait plus de
possibilités de quitter cette île un
quotidien qui a changé qui a basculé il
y a un an avec le début de ce conflit en
U